In 2018, I had what I call
a powerful first experience.
At 31 years old,
I made my first snow angel.
Now, that may not sound
powerful to some of you,
but for me, it was.
And so how do you get
from New York City to Montana?
Well, you have to have a horse.
I don't make the rules,
but not having a horse is why
so many people don't make it out there.
I'm kidding.
I was actually invited to attend
and speak at a conference in Big Sky.
I'm a kid from the Bronx,
so I knew nothing about Big Sky.
I knew nothing about Montana.
In fact, I had only recognized
images similar to it
as the screen saver that comes on
whenever my MacBook goes idle.
I landed in Bozeman and the first thing
I did was thank God,
because I don't like flying,
even though I have to do it often.
I walked out of the airport
and I saw no skyscrapers,
no lines and cabs,
no people yelling and arguing,
and there were no funny smells
that I was familiar with.
You know, all of the things
that make NYC amazing.
So fast forward,
I'm in the passenger seat of the car
and I'm looking out the window
and I'm just taking on the views.
Mountains covered in snow,
trees everywhere.
And at one point we pass by these homes
that had to be worth millions of dollars
because they had the most beautiful
view of the environment.
Later the next day, as I'm getting
off stage from speaking,
a woman comes up to me and she asks,
"Would you like to go on a hike?"
Now I’m from New York City,
so a hike is a few city blocks.
New York City is at sea level,
so we're talking about real oxygen.
So, no, this was a hike.
And at 8,000 feet elevation,
one quickly realizes
Montana's oxygen just isn't real.
(Laughter)
Midway through our hike,
I can't remember what I said,
but the woman grabs a fistful of snow,
puts it in her mouth
and she starts to chew.
And my initial thought was,
"That was disgusting."
I would never touch anything
that touches a New York City street.
But then I realized
this was snow from Montana,
and this was symbolic of the relationships
Montanans have with their environment.
So towards the end of the hike,
this woman lays down in a bed of snow
and she moves her body in a way
where [it] registers to me,
she's making a snow angel.
So after about 30 seconds,
I decide to mimic.
And so I lay in this fresh
bed of snow in Montana,
I move my arms and my legs.
And then it dawns on me.
I'm making a snow angel
for the first time.
And of course, I've seen
other people do it
and I've seen it on television before.
But it was the first time I did it.
You see, I've coined the term
powerful first experiences or PFEs
as doing something you never thought
you would do for the first time,
in a place that you never thought
you would be in for the first time.
The main reason why I was
in Montana in the first place
was to give a talk
about powerful first experiences,
so it was only right
that I would then have
powerful first experiences in Montana.
Powerful first experiences
are life-altering moments and experiences
that change the way that we see ourselves
and changes the way we see the world.
And it can be as expansive
as skydiving out of a plane in France
or as small as visiting a lake
to meditate for the first time.
What matters is your imagination,
your courage and your curiosity.
In the book "Power of Moments"
by Chip and Dan Heath,
the authors reference what psychologists
call the reminiscence bump,
a phenomenon where
older individuals are asked
to think about their experiences,
where they tend to disproportionately talk
about the experiences that happened
roughly between the ages of 15 to 30.
Some researchers say
this is a time in our lives
when we experience the most novelty.
And there's a few theories why.
One, when you enter
and pass through your 30s,
life can seem like it speeds up
because we develop the habits
of doing the same things over and over.
Another reason is that there are just
some experiences in our lives
that are set to happen
within that time frame.
So think about it.
By 15, you might be in high school.
By 18, you may be in college.
After college, you get a job,
you may buy the big home,
you may get married,
you may have a kid.
And then you might
experience loss or grief.
And then you enter your 30s and that's it.
No more powerful first experiences
and life repeats itself over and over.
Something about that
seems so unfulfilling.
Now imagine if you were a kid
from a community like the Bronx.
While the Bronx offers
amazing experiences,
by the time you turn 14 or 15,
you can feel like you've experienced
all the powerful first experiences
in that environment.
And so I became obsessed with figuring out
how to give more powerful
first experiences to others.
My organization, Gentlemen's Retreat,
focuses on young men of color
from the inner city
who end up going to top
colleges and universities,
such as Brown University.
These young men are gifted
and they're special.
They just felt they experienced everything
their community had to offer.
We call these young men Gs for gentlemen.
And while working with these gentlemen
and giving them powerful
first experiences,
I realized it was shaping
their identities in a positive way,
but it was also increasing
their cultural and their social capital.
An individual has cultural capital
because of the environment
that they come from.
The knowledge, skills
and belief of that environment
can be seen as capital or an asset.
And having the combination
allows an individual
to have economic advantages
and other advantages.
And when you collect
powerful first experiences,
you're collecting cultural capital
from different environments.
Social capital is a set
of shared values and resources
that allows individuals to come together
to achieve a common goal.
It can also be thought of as the ability
to access resources and favors
and information from your network.
Countless connections are fostered
when the gentlemen
develop intimate relationships
in places such as Paris, London
and even Montana.
As they spend time
with locals, entrepreneurs
and even venture capitalists.
They develop a more expansive network
and idea of the world.
And increasing cultural and social capital
doesn’t just benefit the gentlemen,
it also benefits the communities
that they bless with their presence.
And a powerful first experience
changes the way you see yourself
and the way you see the world.
Going to Big sky changed
the way that I saw the world,
the way that I saw myself
and what I wanted to do in the world.
Instead of waiting for my cycle
of experiences to repeat themselves,
doing the same things over and over,
I decided to go out into the world
and collect powerful first experiences.
And a powerful first experience
can be anything.
It's all about intention.
The most important part
of a powerful first experience or a PFE,
is intention.
Anyone can have them.
You don't have to have capital
or have started an organization.
You don't even have to be a G.
You just have to be thoughtful
about two things.
One, do something you haven't done
but have always wanted to do.
And what’s important here,
no matter what you choose to do --
skydiving out of a plane,
learning a new language,
switching your wardrobe --
whatever you decide to do,
has to have a certain level
of risk in it for you.
It's about courage.
The courage to get on a plane
and go to a state where most people
don't look like me
in order to experience something
as simple as making a snow angel.
Second thing, switch up your environment,
change the stimuli
and please try to be bold.
So you may be a singer,
but maybe you sing on a crowded
train in New York City
or in the beautiful streets
of Venice, Italy.
Imagine what the world would be like
if we decided to share and exchange in
more powerful first experiences.
Would we feel more loved?
Would we feel more connected?
Would we feel more brave?
Most importantly,
would we feel more human?
Each and every one of us
has so much to experience
if we allow ourselves the gift
of another powerful first experience.
My only ask,
if you decide to go
to Montana for the first time,
please don't forget your horse.
Thank you.
(Applause)